my name is flint lockwood and i've
always wanted to invent something
awesome
he wants to be smart but that's lame
but when my little town fell on hard
times all anyone could afford to eat
were sardines
and because sardines are super gross
gross this was my chance to show
everyone what i was made of conversion
of water into food
i'm sam sparks
looks like things in swallow falls
you know what you are flintlock wood hey
shenaniganizer why can't you be more
like my son cal sup sup
and just when i thought my inventing
days were over
it really worked
i love it any way you want
the first time in my life everybody
loves something that i've done may i
please have waffles
coming right up can you look me in the
eye and tell me son you've got this
under control and it's not going to end
up in a disaster
these are big hot dogs i've got this
under control it's not going to end a
disaster
the machine has a mind of its own we are
about to be in the epicenter of a
perfect food store
no no
moving moving we are running out of time
depends on me
no big deal
cloudy with a chance of meatballs in
mousewatering 3d
you are about to be crushed by a giant
corn